In this lecture, we'll be
using data from MovieLens
to explain clustering and
perform content filtering.
movielens.org is a movie
recommendation website
run by the GroupLens
research lab
at the University of Minnesota.
They collect user
preferences about movies
and do collaborative filtering
to make recommendations
to users, based on the
similarities between users.
We'll use their movie database
to do content filtering
using a technique
called clustering.
First, let's discuss
what data we have.
Movies in the MovieLens
data set are categorized
as belonging to
different genres.
There are 18 different genres
as well as an unknown category.
The genres include
crime, musical, mystery,
and children's.
Each movie may belong to
many different genres.
So a movie could be classified
as drama, adventure,
and sci-fi.
The question we want to answer
is, can we systematically
find groups of movies with
similar sets of genres?
To answer this question, we'll
use a method called clustering.
Clustering is different from
the other analytics methods
we've covered so far.
It's called an unsupervised
learning method.
This means that
we're just trying
to segment the data
into similar groups,
instead of trying to
predict an outcome.
In this image on
the slide, based
on the locations
of points, we've
divided them into three
clusters-- a blue cluster,
a red cluster, and
a yellow cluster.
This is the goal of
clustering-- to put each data
point into a group with
similar values in the data.
A clustering algorithm
does not predict anything.
However, clustering can be used
to improve predictive methods.
You can cluster the
data into similar groups
and then build a predictive
model for each group.
This can often improve the
accuracy of predictive methods.
But as a warning, be careful
not to over-fit your model
to the training set.
This works best for
large data sets.
There are many different
algorithms for clustering.
They differ in what
makes a cluster
and how the clusters are found.
In this class, we'll cover
hierarchical clustering
and K-means clustering.
In this lecture, we'll discuss
hierarchical clustering.
And in the next lecture, we'll
discuss K-means clustering.
You'll learn how to create
clusters using either method
in R. There are other
clustering methods also,
but hierarchical
and K-means are two
of the most popular methods.
To cluster data points,
we need to compute
how similar the points are.
This is done by computing the
distance between points, which
we'll discuss in the next video.